This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. There are lots of reasons to build underground. In Singapore, there are whole skyscrapers under the Earth because the country has run out of space on the surface. In Toronto, Canada, there's a network of tunnels called the Path that connects the whole downtown, so people never have to go outside in the winter. And then there is the curious architecture known as the Doomsday bunker.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在地下建造建筑有很多理由。在新加坡，由于地表空间耗尽，地下建有整座摩天大楼。在加拿大多伦多，有一个名为“PATH”的隧道网络连接着整个市中心，这样人们在冬天就永远不必走到室外。此外，还有一种被称为“末日地堡”的奇特建筑。
There's a huge amount of subterranean space that we're not aware of around us all the time. For those of us who live in suburban and rural areas, it's not unlikely that one of your neighbors has a bunker underneath their house that you don't know about. This is Bradley Garrett. I'm the author of bunker building for the end times. People have always built survival shelters to stay safe from things like plagues or hurricanes. But in modern history, we've really outdone ourselves. There are tens of thousands of government and military bunkers around the world, and every day people are building private bunker space, from simple backyard shelters to luxury condos that extend hundreds of feet underground.
在我们周围，一直存在着大量我们并未察觉的地下空间。对于我们这些住在郊区和农村地区的人来说，你的邻居家里可能就有一个你不知道的地堡。我是布拉德利·加勒特，《末日地堡建造指南》的作者。人类一直以来都在建造生存避难所，以抵御瘟疫或飓风等灾害。但在现代史上，我们确实做得过火了。全球有数以万计的政府和军事地堡，而且每天都有人在建造私人地堡空间，从简单的后院避难所到深入地下数百英尺的豪华公寓，应有尽有。
You know, once you start looking for bunkers, you see them everywhere. In this episode, Brad will be our guide to the fascinating world of architecture for the end times, and we're going to find out why today we're going through a true bunker, Renaissance. Let's talk a little bit about the modern bunker as it relates to the Cold War and the first doom boom. So tell me about it, what happened during the first doom boom? Well, essentially, what happens in the middle of the Cold War is that it becomes clear that the threat of nuclear war is very real. And governments have to make a decision. Are they going to try and build shelter for their entire population?
你知道，一旦你开始寻找地堡，你会发现它们无处不在。在本期节目中，布拉德将带领我们走进迷人的末日建筑世界，我们将探究为什么今天我们正在经历一场真正的“地堡复兴”。让我们谈谈与冷战及第一次“末日热潮”相关的现代地堡。那么，请告诉我，第一次“末日热潮”期间发生了什么？嗯，本质上，在冷战中期，核战争的威胁变得非常真实。政府必须做出决定：他们是否要尝试为全体国民建造避难所？
Some governments actually do this. So Switzerland famously built bunkered space for every single human being in the populace. In fact, there's space for more than everyone. So I don't know, I guess if visitors are in town, they have a place to go as well. Plus one. Yeah. But in the United States, the decision was made not to build these spaces. Because the nuclear strategist that brought these numbers to the Eisenhower government. I mean, the numbers were astronomical. It was essentially the
一些政府确实这样做了。例如，瑞士为每一位国民都建造了地堡空间。事实上，空间比人口还要多。所以我不知道，我想如果城里有游客，他们也有地方可去。加一。是的。但在美国，政府决定不建造这些空间。因为向艾森豪威尔政府提交这些数据的核战略家们——我的意思是，这些数字是天文数字。这基本上相当于
the government's GDP for an entire year to shelter the population. So a decision was made in secret to build bunkers for politicians and their aides, but not their families, interestingly. That becomes, you know, the snowball effect there becomes sort of difficult to deal with. But when Kennedy takes power, he is clearly uncomfortable with the idea that people don't know what kind of danger there is. And so he gives this famous speech where he says that I'm paraphrasing here, and our conflict with the Soviet Union, it's not provocation that we seek but preparation.
政府一整年的GDP来安置人口。因此，政府秘密决定只为政客及其助手建造地堡，有趣的是，并不包括他们的家人。这变成了一种难以处理的“滚雪球效应”。但当肯尼迪上台时，他显然对人们不了解所面临的危险感到不安。于是他发表了那场著名的演讲，他说——我在这里转述一下——在我们与苏联的冲突中，我们寻求的不是挑衅，而是准备。
Our primary purpose is neither propaganda, no provocation, but preparation. Tomorrow, I am requesting of the Congress new funds for the following immediate objective. To identify and mark space in existing structures, public and private. They could be used for fallout, shoulder. He sends out this admonishment to everyone. If you have the resources, build a bunker for yourself and your family. You have to look after yourselves. This triggers what we call the first doom boom, this multi-million dollar industry that springs up overnight of private contractors
我们的主要目的既不是宣传，也不是挑衅，而是准备。明天，我将向国会申请新的资金，用于实现以下即时目标：识别并标记现有公共和私人建筑中的空间，这些空间可以用作防辐射避难所。他向所有人发出劝告：如果你有资源，就为你自己和家人建造一个地堡。你必须照顾好自己。这引发了我们所说的第一次“末日热潮”，一个一夜之间涌现的、价值数百万美元的私人承包商行业，
who are suddenly rushing to excavate people's backyards and build nuclear fallout shelters. Why didn't it seem like a good idea for the US to build shelters for every citizen? Was it just a practical concern of doing the numbers, to widespread, to expensive, or do you think there's something fundamentally different about the relationship between the governance people? Why Switzerland would have a place for everyone plus one? Or was it just practical? That decision has something to do with the way that we imagine the United States as a kind of collective of individuals. But the logistics of building bunkered space for every American was also just incredibly complicated because it's a huge country.
他们突然争先恐后地挖掘人们的后院，建造核防辐射避难所。为什么美国觉得为每一位公民建造避难所不是个好主意？仅仅是因为数字上的实际考量，范围太广、成本太高，还是你认为政府与人民之间的关系存在本质上的不同？为什么瑞士会有容纳所有人的空间外加一个名额？还是仅仅因为实际情况？这个决定与我们将美国想象成一种个人集合体的方式有关。但为每一位美国人建造地堡空间的后勤工作也极其复杂，因为这是一个巨大的国家。
People are really spread out. It wouldn't be fair, for instance, to say, if you live in a densely populated urban area, we're going to make sure that you have access to bunkered space because, logistically, we can offer that. But if you live in a rural area, well, you're on your own. Yeah. The government did make an effort to build fallout shelters rather than blast shelters, right? So that, you know, transforming parking garages, for instance, into a space that people could hide out in. But that's a far cry from what many governments did.
人们分布得非常分散。例如，如果你住在一个人口稠密的城市地区，我们确保你有地堡空间，因为从后勤上讲我们能做到，这并不公平。但如果你住在农村地区，好吧，那就只能靠你自己了。是的。政府确实努力建造防辐射避难所而不是防爆避难所，对吧？所以，你知道，比如将停车场改造成人们可以躲避的空间。但这与许多政府所做的相去甚远。
So could you define the difference between a fallout shelter and a blast shelter, or maybe even a fallout shelter and a bunker, as you see it? In the traditional Cold War calculation, there are two kinds of shelters. There's a blast shelter which can take a direct hit from a nuclear weapon, and there's a fallout shelter, which is a shelter you would hide in for 14 days. 14 days being the magic number when radiation levels fall to the point to which you can sort of safely emerge from the bunker into the post-apocalyptic world. So it's a lot cheaper to build a fallout shelter, obviously.
那么，你能定义一下防辐射避难所和防爆避难所的区别，或者在你看来，防辐射避难所和地堡的区别吗？在传统的冷战计算中，有两种避难所。一种是防爆避难所，可以承受核武器的直接打击；另一种是防辐射避难所，是你需要躲藏14天的避难所。14天是一个神奇的数字，当辐射水平下降到你可以从地堡中安全走出，进入后启示录世界的时候。所以，建造防辐射避难所显然便宜得多。
You know, you don't have to reinforce it to the same degree. It doesn't have to be buried deeply underground. And so many fallout shelters were built during the Cold War, and many of those were private. They were built in people's backyards. The fear of nuclear war started receding in the 1990s, at least my fear of nuclear war, started receding in the 1990s. And you write that some of these private bunkers were converted into pantries and nurseries for kids. What happened to all the government bunkers?
你知道，你不需要进行同等程度的加固。它不需要埋在地下很深的地方。因此，冷战期间建造了许多防辐射避难所，其中许多是私人的。它们建在人们的后院里。对核战争的恐惧在20世纪90年代开始消退，至少我个人对核战争的恐惧是在90年代开始消退的。你写道，其中一些私人地堡被改造成了储藏室和儿童育儿室。那么所有的政府地堡都怎么样了？
If you think about the sums of money that were invested in constructing those massive bunkered spaces for the Cold War, I mean, it's kind of incredible, right? That we, I mean, because of course they now appear to be architectural follies. They never served the function that they were intended for. So what do you do with them? If you're a government and you're now sort of operating under varying levels of austerity and you're trying to scramble to find money for things and then you realize, hey, wait a minute,
如果你想想冷战时期投入到建造那些巨大地堡空间里的巨额资金，我的意思是，这真是令人难以置信，对吧？因为它们现在看起来像是建筑上的愚行。它们从未发挥过预期的功能。那么你该拿它们怎么办呢？如果你是一个政府，现在正处于不同程度的紧缩政策下，正试图到处筹钱，然后你意识到，嘿，等等，
we've got that subterranean fortress that we built that we never used. Maybe we could put that on the private market. This has happened over and over again. Governments put their bunkers up for sale and very often the people who want to buy those spaces are not doomsday preppers, right? People want to put data servers and mushroom farms and wine sellers and all sorts of things, but they are competing with people who genuinely believe that we're things, but they are competing with people who genuinely believe that we're headed towards a precipice. And they're interested in buying those bunkered spaces and moving them into
我们有一个从未用过的地下堡垒。也许我们可以把它放到私人市场上。这种情况一再发生。政府将他们的地堡挂牌出售，而通常想要购买这些空间的人并不是末日生存狂，对吧？人们想放数据服务器、蘑菇农场、酒窖以及各种各样的东西，但他们正在与那些真正相信我们正走向悬崖的人竞争。他们有兴趣购买这些地堡空间，并将它们推向
the private market. And it's a very lucrative business. If you can afford to pay a million dollars for a defunct government bunker, and then retrofit that with some fresh technology and a paint job and sell space inside that bunker to private individuals. You know, it's a booming real estate market right now. Demand for bunkers went down after the Cold War, but in the last few years, it's gone way back up. The tech website, The Verge, reported that, according to a bunch of companies, the demand for bunkers space in America has reached an all-time high since the beginning of the coronavirus pandemic.
私人市场。这是一项非常有利可图的生意。如果你能负担得起一百万美元买一个废弃的政府地堡，然后用一些新技术和油漆进行翻新，再把地堡里的空间卖给私人。你知道，现在这是一个蓬勃发展的房地产市场。冷战后对地堡的需求下降了，但在过去几年里，需求又大幅回升。科技网站《The Verge》报道称，据多家公司称，自新冠疫情开始以来，美国对地堡空间的需求已达到历史最高水平。
Do you think this is an anomaly or part of a bigger trend? In contrast to the Cold War, where we had a kind of specific anxiety about a very particular event, I think people now are just generally anxious about everything. So if we think about existential threats, the threats that have the possibility
你认为这是一种反常现象，还是更大趋势的一部分？与冷战时期我们对某个特定事件有某种特定的焦虑不同，我认为人们现在对一切都普遍感到焦虑。所以如果我们考虑生存威胁，那些有可能
of wiping us out as a species, nuclear war was clearly an existential threat. But now we worry about climate change, we worry about artificial intelligence, we worry about viral outbreaks, you know, potentially one that's much more fatal than what we're dealing with. There's a calculation there that is incalculable, that people are trying to make every day. Some people respond by becoming apathetic or trying to dull their senses to make it through these things, and other people respond by trying to control the parameters of their life that are
将我们作为一个物种彻底消灭的威胁，核战争显然是一个生存威胁。但现在我们担心气候变化，担心人工智能，担心病毒爆发，你知道，可能比我们正在处理的更致命。这里有一个无法计算的计算，人们每天都在尝试进行。有些人通过变得冷漠或试图麻痹自己的感官来度过这些事情，而另一些人则通过试图控制他们周围的生命参数来做出反应。
immediately around them. So I would argue that we're in the midst of a second doom boom at the moment. That doom boom is, you know, bunker building is part of it. People are building private bunkers as they were in the Cold War, but they're we're also building these massive communal bunkers for multiple families. There's a thriving market in survival foods, freeze-dried foods, escape vehicles, bug out vehicles, people are buying, I mean, look at how the market for humb these, right? Private market that we're seeing spring up all around us, which is now a multi-billion dollar market, selling all of these products to alleviate people's dread about an uncertain future. That is all part of the second doom boom that we're in the midst of right now.
所以我认为我们目前正处于第二次“末日热潮”之中。那场“末日热潮”是，你知道，地堡建造是其中的一部分。人们像冷战时期一样建造私人地堡，但我们也在为多个家庭建造这些巨大的公共地堡。生存食品、冷冻干燥食品、逃生车辆、撤离车辆的市场非常繁荣，人们正在购买——我的意思是，看看这些市场的需求，对吧？我们在周围看到的私人市场，现在是一个价值数十亿美元的市场，销售所有这些产品来缓解人们对不确定未来的恐惧。这都是我们目前正处于的第二次“末日热潮”的一部分。
So how many people are actively prepping in those ways? I'm supposed to be a social scientist. Let me give you some numbers here. In 2011, there was a survey done where 3.7 million Americans admitted that they were actively prepping. That was broadly conceived. So that could have been people just putting an emergency kit in their garage and thinking about, I mean, in California, we all do this. Yeah, I mean, that's the thing.
那么有多少人正在以这些方式积极准备？我应该是一名社会科学家。让我给你一些数据。2011年的一项调查显示，有370万美国人承认他们正在积极准备。这是广义上的概念。所以这可能是人们只是在车库里放了一个应急包，并考虑——我的意思是，在加州，我们都这样做。是的，我的意思是，就是这样。
It's really part of the culture. You get a bucket that has all that stuff in it or you have a solar power, crank radio. I mean, it's sort of like expected. It is expected on a low level, right? Now, here's the shocking statistic. There's a researcher at Cornell University, a PhD student, Chris Ellis, who took some survey data from FEMA. They had conducted surveys in 2017 and 2018
这确实是文化的一部分。你有一个装满所有东西的桶，或者你有一个太阳能手摇收音机。我的意思是，这在某种程度上是预料之中的。这在低水平上是预料之中的，对吧？现在，这里有一个令人震惊的统计数据。康奈尔大学的一名博士生克里斯·埃利斯（Chris Ellis）利用了联邦紧急事务管理局（FEMA）的一些调查数据，他们在2017年和2018年进行了调查
in every state and territory. And they found that there were extrapolating those statistics that there were almost 12 million Americans who were prepared to survive for 30 days without any kind of state infrastructure, no water, no electricity, no internet, no restaurants, no grocery stores. Almost 12 million Americans are currently prepared to do that. Ellis in his research, he calls these people resilient citizens. And what was really fascinating is that per capita, the most resilient citizens in the country were native Hawaiians and Pacific Islanders, many of whom are already growing food or
在每个州和地区。他们发现，推断这些统计数据，有近1200万美国人准备在没有任何国家基础设施的情况下生存30天，没有水、没有电、没有互联网、没有餐馆、没有杂货店。近1200万美国人目前准备这样做。埃利斯在他的研究中称这些人为“韧性公民”。真正令人着迷的是，按人均计算，全国最坚韧的公民是夏威夷原住民和太平洋岛民，他们中的许多人已经在种植食物或
live off grid. So they're kind of better prepared than people like myself who've been living in cities for 15 years and have absolutely no idea how to grow food. I guess the final takeaway there is that those numbers are from 2017 and 2018. Imagine what they're going to look like in 2021 when we collect that data again. I think so many people have been pulled into the orbit of what I would call practical prepping. Prepping for like just basic everyday functionality rather than a kind of doomsday scenario. I think that those numbers
过着离网生活。所以他们比我这种在城市里住了15年，完全不知道怎么种地的人准备得更好。我想最后的结论是，这些数字来自2017年和2018年。想象一下，当我们在2021年再次收集这些数据时，它们会是什么样子。我认为有太多人被卷入了所谓的“实用准备”轨道。为基本的日常功能做准备，而不是为某种末日场景做准备。我认为这些数字
are going to just, there's going to be a meteoric rise in the next couple of years. You went out and explored some of the architecture of the new Doom Boom. there's gonna be a meteoric rise in the next couple of years. You went out and explored some of the architecture of the new Doom Boom. What was the most impressive piece of architecture that you came across? This was the great joy of the book was going to see people's bunkers. And as you can imagine, most people don't want you to see.
将会出现，在接下来的几年里将会出现飞速增长。你出去探索了一些新“末日热潮”的建筑。在接下来的几年里将会出现飞速增长。你出去探索了一些新“末日热潮”的建筑。你遇到的最令人印象深刻的建筑是什么？这是写这本书的一大乐趣，就是去看人们的地堡。正如你可以想象的那样，大多数人不想让你看到。
So it took a lot of trust building, to get to the point where people would send those invitations. But one of the best invitations I received was from a Canadian who was living in Thailand. I was in Sydney at the time. I was at the University of Sydney and he sent me a message and he said, I'm building a bunker. It's in the countryside. I would love for you to come out and see the thing.
所以这需要建立很多信任，才能达到人们愿意发出邀请的地步。但我收到的最好的邀请之一来自一位住在泰国的加拿大人。当时我在悉尼，在悉尼大学，他给我发了一条信息，说：“我正在建一个地堡。它在乡下。我很乐意让你来看看。”
And of course, I immediately flew over there to go and see it. And in contrast to many of the prepers that I met, this guy was like, he was very, very cool, very collected. The story that he told me was simply that he moved to Thailand to marry a woman that he met in a DVD rental store way back in the day. And they had a wonderful life in Thailand, but he was working on offshore oil fields. And so he was often away for two or three months at a time. And eventually they had a child, and he was worried about them all the time. And he admitted that he was spending his time digging through the news for bad stories. And so he kept moving them into more and more fortified gated communities, and then eventually decided, I'm going to build a bunker. So he bought a plot of land in an
当然，我立刻飞过去看了看。与我见过的许多生存狂相比，这家伙非常非常酷，非常冷静。他告诉我的故事很简单：他搬到泰国是为了娶一个他在很久以前的DVD租赁店认识的女人。他们在泰国过着美好的生活，但他一直在海上油田工作，所以他经常一走就是两三个月。最终他们有了孩子，他一直很担心他们。他承认他一直在新闻里寻找坏消息。所以他不断地把他们搬进越来越坚固的封闭式社区，最后决定：“我要建一个地堡。”于是他在一个
abandoned orchard. And his plan was to create four blocks that were these villas. He called it sanctum. And he was going to live in the first block, and he was going to sell off the other three to pay for the first. And the block that he was building, which I had the opportunity to see, was an incredible thing. It was a giant concrete square with no windows. But the place was beautiful. It was open at the top, light flooded through the middle of it. It dropped down into a swimming pool and underneath the swimming pool, there was a nuclear blast shelter that he had actually turned into a day spa. So it didn't feel like a shelter. And that was his idea.
废弃的果园里买了一块地。他的计划是建造四个街区，也就是这些别墅。他称之为“圣所”。他打算住在第一个街区，并卖掉其他三个来支付第一个的费用。他正在建造的那个街区，我有机会看到，是一个不可思议的东西。它是一个巨大的混凝土方块，没有窗户。但这个地方很美，顶部是开放的，光线从中间倾泻而下。它向下延伸到一个游泳池，在游泳池下面，有一个他实际上改造成日间水疗中心的核防爆避难所。所以它感觉不像一个避难所。这就是他的想法。
He had passion fruit vines growing down the walls inside and it was totally self-sufficient so he drilled wells. He had solar panels on the top of the building. He actually won some architectural awards for the sustainability elements in the building. But essentially it was a fortress and we were standing on the rooftop there and I was looking around and I realized that we were in this incredibly remote village, like people were living in small huts, everything was totally open. Most people didn't have doors or windows and he had built this fortress here and then I looked off into the distance and I could see a Buddhist monastery, this huge gold statue
他在墙内种了百香果藤，而且完全自给自足，所以他打了井。他在建筑顶部安装了太阳能电池板。他实际上因为建筑中的可持续性元素赢得了一些建筑奖项。但本质上它是一个堡垒。我们站在屋顶上，我环顾四周，意识到我们身处这个极其偏远的村庄，就像人们住在小棚屋里一样，一切都是完全开放的。大多数人没有门窗，而他在这里建了一座堡垒。然后我向远处望去，我可以看到一座佛教寺庙，那座巨大的金佛像
of Buddha that was staring at this fortress. I was impressed with the building, but I was also very kind of taken by the idea that I was in this remote place, and rural Thailand, and even here, someone was building a bunker waiting for the end of the places you visited was a place called Survival Condo, which is a luxury bunker. What is it like in a luxury bunker? Like how nice could it be? Yeah, Survival Condo was built by an ex-government contractor called Larry Hall. And he used to work on defense projects for the government, including building bunkers. And when he had the opportunity to break out
正盯着这座堡垒。我对这座建筑印象深刻，但我也被这个想法所吸引：我身处这个偏远的地方，在泰国农村，即使在这里，也有人在建造地堡等待末日。你参观过的地方之一是一个叫“生存公寓”（Survival Condo）的地方，这是一个豪华地堡。豪华地堡是什么样的？它能有多好？是的，“生存公寓”是由一位名叫拉里·霍尔（Larry Hall）的前政府承包商建造的。他过去常为政府从事国防项目，包括建造地堡。当他有机会脱离
and work on his own projects, he decided he was gonna build his own bunker. I asked him why, and he said, you don't wanna know. Which was really just concerning. It was implying that you knew of dangers you didn't know about. And that's why you're building this bunker. Yes, okay.
并从事自己的项目时，他决定建造自己的地堡。我问他为什么，他说：“你不会想知道的。”这真的很令人担忧。这暗示着你知道一些我们不知道的危险。这就是你建造这个地堡的原因。是的，好吧。
Precisely, yeah. And I have to say, a of the people that that I met who are prepping used to work for the government and You know it could be that if you're in those sorts of roles you end up Seeing Disconcerting things and that makes you think about the world in a particular way or it could be that they know something we don't know in a particular way, or it could be that they know something we don't know. But Larry Hall, he purchased a nuclear missile silo that used to have an intercontinental ballistic missile inside of it in the middle of Kansas. And so I'm sure many of your listeners will know, but there are two kinds of nuclear silos, right?
确实，是的。我必须说，我遇到的许多正在做准备的人过去都为政府工作。你知道，可能是因为如果你担任这些角色，你最终会看到令人不安的事情，这让你以特定的方式思考世界；或者可能是因为他们知道一些我们不知道的事情，或者可能是因为他们知道一些我们不知道的事情。但拉里·霍尔，他在堪萨斯州中部购买了一个曾经装有洲际弹道导弹的核导弹发射井。所以我相信你们的许多听众会知道，核发射井有两种，对吧？
They're the horizontal ones and the vertical ones, so this is one of the vertical ones. Obviously, the missile had been removed. The place was actually flooded. It was in the middle of cornfields and all this sort of agricultural runoff had filled the silo. He pumped that all out of there and he turned this into, I described it in my book as a geoscraper. It's sort of the opposite of a skyscraper. It's 15 stories, but it goes into the earth. You drive through the giant blast doors at the top of this thing. You drive into the parking garage and then you take the elevator down. As you descend, you move first through levels that contain condominiums, both full floor
有水平的，也有垂直的，所以这是垂直的那种。显然，导弹已经被移走了。这个地方实际上被淹了。它位于玉米地中间，所有这些农业径流都填满了发射井。他把所有这些都抽了出来，把它变成了一个——我在书中把它描述为“地底摩天大楼”（geoscraper）。它有点像摩天大楼的对立面。它有15层，但它是深入地下的。你开车穿过这个东西顶部的巨大防爆门。你开进停车场，然后乘电梯下去。当你下降时，你首先经过包含公寓的楼层，既有全层
and half floor condominiums, both full-floor and half-floor condominiums. And then when you get to the bottom of the facility, you've got the kind of communal facilities. He had hired a psychologist to educate him about what people needed to survive. And of course, the base level needs are easy. You know, you can give people food and clean air and clean water. But what gets tricky is how you keep people there for three weeks or three months or three years. He had introduced all of these elements on the advice of the psychologist that would keep people from going nuts or hurting each other or whatever inside the bunker. There's a gym, a yoga studio, a shooting range, climbing wall,
也有半层公寓。当你到达设施底部时，你会有那种公共设施。他雇了一位心理学家来教育他人们生存需要什么。当然，基础需求很容易。你知道，你可以给人们食物、干净的空气和干净的水。但棘手的是如何让人们在那里待三周、三个月或三年。在心理学家的建议下，他引入了所有这些元素，以防止人们在地堡里发疯、互相伤害或做其他什么事。那里有健身房、瑜伽室、射击场、攀岩墙、
swimming pool, a fully stocked bar. And the thing that's really interesting about Survival Kondo is that Larry Hall was very clear about the fact that he was building this for wealthy people. He was building this for people who actually didn't want to take any responsibility for their own preparations. They wanted to pay him to do everything. They wanted to turn key solution. So he sells half floor condos for 1.5 million and full floor condos for 3 million.
游泳池、设备齐全的酒吧。关于“生存公寓”，真正有趣的是，拉里·霍尔非常清楚他是在为富人建造这个。他是在为那些实际上不想为自己的准备工作承担任何责任的人建造。他们想付钱让他做所有事情。他们想要一个交钥匙的解决方案。所以他以150万美元的价格出售半层公寓，以300万美元的价格出售全层公寓。
You have to pay with cash because what bank is going to finance your doomsday bunker. And it's an incredible facility. It's incredibly comfortable. In fact, I was in the middle of writing the book and I said, do you want someone to test this for you? Because I would be very happy to stay down here for three months and finish writing the book. He didn't take me up on that offer.
你必须用现金支付，因为哪家银行会为你的末日地堡提供融资呢？这是一个不可思议的设施。它非常舒适。事实上，我当时正在写这本书，我说：“你想让人为你测试一下吗？因为我很乐意在这里待上三个月，写完这本书。”他没有接受我的提议。
So right, Wakanda was kind of the high end. It cost a million and a half dollars to get a unit there or three million to get a fancy or unit. But you did visit for a range, another place called X Point. I think you sort of suggested it as a potential to be more widespread and functional because it's not exactly a luxury punk of community. So what was it like at X Point and who were they trying to attract? So it was built during World War II.
所以，好吧，“生存公寓”算是高端的。在那里买一个单元要花150万美元，或者300万美元买一个更豪华的单元。但你确实参观了另一个叫“X点”（X Point）的地方。我想你把它建议为一种更有可能普及和实用的选择，因为它不是那种豪华地堡社区。那么“X点”是什么样的？他们试图吸引什么样的人？它是在二战期间建造的。
It was actually a munitions storage complex. And the Army Corps of Engineers built these semi-subterranean concrete igloos, they called them. They kind of have that shape. And they built 575 of them in this huge expansive land in the middle of the plains in South Dakota. I forget the square footage, but it's about three quarters of the size of Manhattan, this bunker field. And at one time, they would have filled all of these bunkers with weapons to protect them from other weapons. Strange irony there. And now they're filled with people who are protecting themselves from weapons, potentially. Or viruses or zombies. Or viruses or yeah, it's on the zombie apocalypse. This was another real estate development project that was pitched by a Doomsday Prepper. His
它实际上是一个弹药储存综合体。陆军工程兵团建造了这些半地下的混凝土冰屋，他们称之为“冰屋”。它们确实有那种形状。他们在南达科他州平原中间的一大片土地上建造了575个。我忘了具体的平方英尺，但这个地堡群大约有曼哈顿四分之三那么大。曾经有一段时间，他们会用武器填满所有这些地堡，以保护它们免受其他武器的伤害。这里有一种奇怪的讽刺。现在，它们里面住满了正在保护自己免受武器伤害的人。或者病毒，或者僵尸。或者病毒，或者是的，僵尸启示录。这是另一个由末日生存狂提出的房地产开发项目。他的
name is Robert Vesino. He lives in California. And when he saw this bunker field, he saw it as an incredible opportunity to create what he described to me as The place from which humanity would be reborn After the next great calamity he very much saw it as a kind of Calling he was gonna build this place. So he found this bunker field in South Dakota This is another one of these Architectural spaces that the government has a really
名字叫罗伯特·维西诺（Robert Vicino）。他住在加州。当他看到这个地堡群时，他认为这是一个不可思议的机会，可以创造出他向我描述的“人类在下一次大灾难后重生的场所”。他非常将其视为一种使命。他要建造这个地方。所以他在南达科他州找到了这个地堡群。这是政府非常难以处理的另一种建筑空间。
hard time dealing with. What do you do with a giant bunker field? Who do you sell it to? So when they had a real estate developer approach them and saying, I've got a viable business plan. They said, fantastic. Please take this off of our hands. And Vesino, he started cleaning up and selling empty concrete igloos for $25,000. I was there on day one. I saw the first four families move into their bunkers. They were working class people. People were building there.
你拿一个巨大的地堡群怎么办？你把它卖给谁？所以当他们有房地产开发商接近他们说：“我有一个可行的商业计划。”他们说：“太棒了。请把它从我们手中接走。”维西诺开始清理并以25,000美元的价格出售空的混凝土冰屋。我在第一天就在那里。我看到前四个家庭搬进了他们的地堡。他们是工薪阶层。人们在那里工作。
They were interested in building a space that would become essentially a second home. Rather than purchasing the second home, they buy the bunker and turn it into the second home. It's kind of their vacation property. So they would go there for Fourth of July, for instance. They would have big parties with all of the other bunker residents.
他们有兴趣建造一个本质上会成为第二个家的空间。他们不是购买第二个家，而是购买地堡并将其改造成第二个家。这算是他们的度假房产。所以他们会在7月4日之类的节日去那里。他们会和其他所有地堡居民举行大型派对。
But no one was really interested in living there permanently. Because to be frank, it's a very rough environment. It's windy, it's dry, it's cold. It would be really hard to live in these bunkers permanently. Not to mention that in the beginning, there was no running water or sanitation infrastructure. That did come later. The families that are living there now
但没有人真正有兴趣永久住在那里。因为坦率地说，那是一个非常恶劣的环境。风大、干燥、寒冷。永久住在这些地堡里会非常困难。更不用说在最初，没有自来水或卫生基础设施。那确实是后来才有的。现在住在那里或在那里有空间的家庭
are living in, or that have space there, are living in decent comfort. This is something I found interesting, and I wonder if you thought about this too. It seems to me, and these are with broad sociological terms, that the person who builds or is attracted to a bunker is kind of a self-reliant, libertarian, maybe minded person who is trying to solve this problem on their own because, and they probably think that they should solve a lot of problems on their own. But they're buying into this commune in the post-apocalyptic world that might run counter the how they would live their lives today, but they maybe think that this sort of like
生活得还算舒适。我发现这一点很有趣，我想知道你是否也考虑过这个问题。在我看来——这是用广泛的社会学术语来说——建造地堡或被地堡吸引的人是一种自力更生、自由意志主义、也许是这种心态的人，他们试图独自解决这个问题，因为——他们可能认为他们应该独自解决很多问题。但他们正在加入这个后启示录世界的公社，这可能与他们今天的生活方式背道而驰，但他们可能认为这种末日事件会重新调整他们的利益或什么的。你采访过那些考虑过这种转变对他们来说会是什么感觉的人吗？从人们那里得到的最困难的事情之一是他们想象中的后启示录世界是什么样的。每个人都想象着建造——你知道，每个人现在都在建造，对吧？他们可以想象他们想要建造的地堡。我是在宽泛地使用“地堡”这个词，对吧？这种无论什么空间，他们的偏远房产或他们的地下地堡，无论什么。
the Stoomstay event would realign their interests or something. Have you interviewed people who thought about what that transition would feel like for them? One of the most difficult things to get out of people is what they imagine the post-apocalyptic world to be like. Everyone imagines building, you know, everyone's building now, right? And they can imagine the bunker they want to build. I'm using bunker loosely, right? That this kind of whatever space, their remote property or their subterranean bunker, whatever.
他们可以想象那个事件，那个驱使他们进入地堡的事情。然后他们经常想象这种解脱的时刻。我不用再去上班了。我不用再参与社会了。我的手机没用了，对吧？互联网坏了。人们向我表达过这种欣快感
And they can imagine the event, the thing that drives them into the bunker. And then they imagine very often this kind of moment of relief. I don't have to go to work anymore. I don't have to participate in society. My phone doesn't work, right? The internet's broken. There's this kind of euphoria that people have expressed to me over
一次又一次，关于被困在地堡里的想法，也许和几个，你知道，他们认为志同道合的人在一起。但我们从来没有真正得到长期的愿景。我们带着这个走向哪里？在那之后你建立了什么样的社会？那些可能也非常依赖自己、不信任政府处理紧急情况的人，现在你和这些人在一起了。你必须重建。当我开始与人们进行这些对话时，他们往往会在那个点上停滞不前。
and over again about the idea of being like trapped in the bunker, maybe with a couple of, you know, what they would consider like-minded people. But we never really get to the long-term vision. Where are we headed with this? What kind of society do you build after that? Those people who might also have depended very much on themselves and mistrusted the government to deal with emergencies, you're now in a community with those people. And you have to rebuild when I entered into those conversations with people, often they would stall out at that point.
许多地堡生存狂的准备方式确实是针对他们自己和家人的。这是非常个人主义的。就像没有人会告诉他们该做什么。然而，你交谈过的一些生存狂似乎完全准备好在灾难后给人们分配角色。就像，“你当面包师，你当医生。”就像他们在建立一个公社。
Many of the bunker preppers are prepping in a way that it's really geared towards them and their family. It's very individualistic. Like no one's going to tell them what to do. And yet some of the preppers you talk to seem totally ready to assign people roles after the disaster. Like, you know, you'll be a baker and you'll be a doctor. Like they're making a commune.
这让我觉得是一个有趣的矛盾。我认为这是乌托邦的一部分，想象所有传统的角色都被打破，这是一种讽刺，对吧？因为这些人中的许多人非常固守于事情应该如何运作的传统观念。但我们也应该小心，不要给生存狂贴太多标签，因为纽约皇后大学的安娜玛丽·邦兹（Annamarie Bounds）有一些出色的研究，她与城市生存狂合作，她与内城生存狂的特定生存狂网络合作，他们中的大多数是黑人，大多数人说他们过去经历过创伤。他们经历过
It strikes me as a funny contradiction. That's part of the utopia, I think, is imagining all of the traditional roles being broken, which is an irony, right? Because a lot of these people are very stuck in traditional notions of how things should function. But we should also be careful not to character preppers too much because there's some brilliant research by Annamarie Bounds at Queens University in New York where she worked with urban preppers and she worked with the specific preppers network of inner city preppers, most of whom were black and most of whom said that they had been through traumatic experiences in the past. They'd been through
桑迪飓风。他们经历过9/11。他们有过艰难的童年，他们说：“我们再也不会回到那种状态了。”所以对他们来说，囤积、存钱、为紧急情况做准备和技能培养。对他们来说，这都是一种努力，试图让他们保持在他们心中所攀登到的空间。稍后我们将继续与布拉德利·加勒特交流。你在为这本书做研究和写作的过程中，你对准备工作的看法发生了什么变化？生存狂打破了我所有的期望。
Sandy. They'd been through 9-11. They'd had difficult childhoods and they said, we're not going back there. So stockpiling for them and saving money and preparing for emergencies and skill building. For them, that was all an effort to kind of keep themselves in the space that they had climbed to in their minds. We'll have more with Bradley Garrett after this. How did your outlook on prepping change while you're doing the research for this book and writing the book? Preppers defied all my expectations.
他们比我预期的更多样化。他们比我预期的更冷静。我在与他们相处的时间里意识到我缺乏多少技能，我对很多事情的了解有多么少。这也给我带来了一点我无法摆脱的恐惧，你知道，这种对我们走向何方以及这一切目的是什么的不确定性。我想这在某种程度上动摇了我的信念
They were more diverse than I expected. They were calmer than I expected. I realized in the time that I spent with them how many skills I was lacking and how little knowledge I had about so many things. It's also introduced a bit of dread in me that I can't shake, you know, this kind of uncertainty about where we're headed and what the purpose of all this is. I guess it's kind of shaken my faith
动摇了我对这种启蒙轨迹的信念，即我们应该只是升级到乌托邦之类的东西。我一直遇到这种感觉，他们认为时间是螺旋式前进的。崩溃是不可避免的。明天将与今天不同。
in this kind of shaken my faith in this kind of enlightenment trajectory where we're supposed to be just escalating into utopia or whatever. I kept running into this feeling that they saw time as moving in spirals. Like breakdown was inevitable. Tomorrow is gonna be different than today.
这没关系。就像他们今天对这一点感到平静一样。这没关系。他们对那个想法感到平静。在我开始这个项目之前，我不是。我总是希望明天比今天更好。这实际上让我感到焦虑，不断地思考我还需要实现什么，或者我接下来应该在哪个大学工作。在接下来的10年里我应该写多少本书？你知道，我不在乎了。我的意思是，我在乎，但我猜那种关心——那种对我职业生涯和那种轨迹的痴迷——现在已经得到了缓和。
And that's okay. Like they were at peace with that today. That's okay. They were at peace with that idea. Before I started working on this project, I wasn't. I wanted tomorrow to be better than today, always. It was actually filling me with anxiety, continuing to think constantly about what more I needed to achieve or what university should I work at next. How many books should I write in the next 10 years? You know, and I just don't care anymore. I mean, I do care, but I guess that care has been that kind of obsession with my career and that trajectory has been tempered now.
你知道，我的意思是，疫情也对此做出了贡献。因为我一直被困在这里照顾我的家人，这很棒。这对我来说实际上是一个治愈的过程。但当我开始写这本书时，我不知道会发生疫情。所以有一种，我不知道，只是完美的渐强，把我带到了这个地方，让我对我的生活感觉好多了。这就是生存狂告诉我的。他们说灾难——我的意思是，我们不知道灾难会是什么，但他们说灾难会强行重新调整你的优先事项。
You know, I mean, the pandemic has also contributed to it. Because I've been stuck here with my family taking care of them, and that's been great. It's been actually a healing process for me. But when I started writing this book, I had no idea there was going to be a pandemic. So there was this kind of, I don't know, just perfect crescendo that has led me to this place where I feel so much better about my life. And that's what the preppers told me. They said the disaster, I mean, we didn't know what the disaster was going to be, but they said the disaster will forcefully realign your priorities.
我的意思是，当你与那些参与其中、建造或居住在加固建筑中、稍微准备了一些地堡的人交谈时，你是否觉得他们的恐惧被周围的这些东西缓解了，还是被周围的这些东西加剧了？我本以为会找到一群焦虑和偏执的人，但他们真的不是。他们觉得他们已经控制了周围的参数。他们实际上生活在一种深刻的平静感中，无论他们正在处理或可能必须处理的外部环境如何，他们已经把他们需要的一切都准备好了，以确保生存的最佳可能性。你知道，你不能保证生存，但你可以确保生存的最佳可能性。
I mean, when you talk to people who were sort of engaged with this, who like built or lived in hardened architecture, had bunkers prepped a bit, did you feel that their fears were being asswaged by this stuff surrounding them or stoked by this stuff surrounding them. I expected to find a group of people who were anxious and paranoid, and they really weren't. They felt that they had taken control of the parameters around them. They lived with a profound sense of peace, actually, regardless of the external circumstances that they were dealing with or might have to deal with, they had put everything in place that they needed to assure the best possibility of survival. You know, you can't assure survival, but you can assure the best possibility of survival.
几千年后，当人类消失时，会剩下什么？会是帝国大厦吗？你认为会是末日地堡吗？看看大西洋壁垒，那些二战时期的地堡，就像巨大的机器人头盔，它们瘫倒在诺曼底的海滩上。那些东西一千年后还会存在。我们现在正在建造纪念碑，这个时代的纪念碑。它们可能会比我们活得更久。你知道，可能是其他出现的物种最终发现了我们建造的这些巨大的地堡和地下堡垒。他们会讲述一个害怕自己的文明的故事。我曾经是一名考古学家
Thousands of years from now, when humanity has gone, what is going to be left? Will it be the Empire State Building? What do you think it'll be apocalypse bunkers? Just look at the Atlantic wall Those bunkers from World War two that are like giant robot helmets and they're slumped into the beaches of Normandy Those things are gonna be there in a thousand years. We are building Monuments right now monuments to this age. They may outlast us. You know, it could be some other species that emerges that eventually finds these giant bunkers and subterranean fortresses that we built. And they're going to tell a story about a civilization that was that is afraid of itself. I used to be an archaeologist
我在墨西哥一个叫图卢姆（Tulum）的遗址工作，所以是后古典玛雅遗址。这些人拥有你能想象到的最理想的生活方式，他们有点像在海滩上建造寺庙，有美丽的蓝色海水。而在最后，所以最终他们消失了，像每个文明一样。而在最后，根据物质记录，他们开始在
and I worked in Mexico at a site called Tulum, so post-classic Maya site. And these people had the most ideal lifestyle, you can imagine, they sort of built temples on the beach and there's beautiful blue water. And right at the end, so eventually they disappear, like every civilization. Right at the end, so eventually they disappear, right, like every civilization. Right at the end, according to the material records, they start building these walls around
他们的寺庙周围建造这些墙。他们以前从来没有墙。没有人知道他们为什么开始建造它们。有些人说他们与某个闹翻的人发生了战争，但还有另一种理论，实际上是因为病毒。当西班牙人过来，人们开始被感染时，他们不知道那是什么。所以他们开始筑墙来抵御病毒。
their temples. And they never had walls before. And no one knows why they started building them. Some people have said that they were engaged in warfare with someone that they had a falling out with, but there's another theory that actually it was because of viruses. When the Spanish came over and people started getting infected, they didn't know what it was. And so they started building walls to keep the virus out.
他们的神庙。他们以前从未修筑过城墙。没人知道他们为什么开始建造城墙。有些人说他们当时与某人发生了冲突，陷入了战争，但还有另一种理论认为，这实际上是因为病毒。当西班牙人到来，人们开始受到感染时，他们不知道那是什么。于是他们开始筑墙，试图将病毒挡在外面。
Those walls are still there today, but it occurs to me that the walls that we're building now are going to tell a similar story of a people who were scared and uncertain about the future who aren't sure where they're headed. I think one of the most interesting aspects of the bunker as an architectural space is actually imagining it as the future archaeology. Bradley Gears book is called Bunker, building for the end times. It is so good. If you're fascinated by this stuff at all, you're going to love this book. There's so much in it that we did not cover here. You can get it now in hard back, and it will be out in paperback later this year.
这些墙壁至今依然存在，但我意识到，我们现在建造的墙壁也将讲述类似的故事：讲述一群对未来感到恐惧和不安、不确定自己走向何方的人们。我认为地堡作为一种建筑空间，最有趣的一面在于将其想象成未来的考古学。布拉德利·吉尔的书名为《地堡：为末日而建》。这本书非常棒。如果你对这些内容感兴趣，你一定会喜欢这本书。书中有很多我们在这里没有涉及的内容。你现在可以买到精装版，平装版将于今年晚些时候出版。
99% Invisible was produced this week by Chris Barube, music by Sean Rial, sound mix by Amita Ganatra. Our senior producer is Delaney Hall, Kurt Colesette is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Emmett Fitzgerald, Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Le, Christopher Johnson, Abby Medon, Katie Mingle, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 K-A-L-W in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, which is scattered in little audio bunkers across the continent, but when the end times come, we will run straight to beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. We are a founding member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of
本周的《99% Invisible》由克里斯·巴鲁贝制作，音乐由肖恩·里亚尔创作，混音由阿米塔·加纳特拉完成。我们的高级制作人是德莱尼·霍尔，库尔特·科尔塞特担任数字总监。团队其他成员包括埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、乔·罗森伯格、薇薇安·勒、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、艾比·梅登、凯蒂·明格尔、索菲亚·克拉茨克，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7 K-A-L-W的一个项目，制作于“广播街”，它分散在大陆各处的小型音频地堡中，但当末日来临时，我们将直接奔向美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。我们是PRX旗下Radio Topia的创始成员，这是一个极其独立的集体，由
the most innovative listeners supported 100% artist-owned podcasts in the world. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can tweet me at Roman Mars in the show at 9i.pi.org, or on Instagram and Reddit too. If you want to see pictures of bunkers and a link to the book, bunker, building for the end times, it's so good. You're going to want to get it. Look no further than 99pi.org. Radio Tapio. From PRX.
世界上最具创新性、由听众支持、100%艺术家拥有的播客组成。请访问radiotopia.fm了解详情。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@9i.pi.org，也可以在Instagram和Reddit上关注我们。如果你想看地堡的照片以及《地堡：为末日而建》这本书的链接，这本书真的太棒了，你一定会想买的。请访问99pi.org。Radio Topia，来自PRX。
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你 目前这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。